ahora vamos a hablar de cómo hallar el
plano tangente a una gráfica y creo que
el primer paso es entender cómo
controlar estos planos en tres
dimensiones y lo que tengo aquí es un
punto rojo que representa un punto en
tres dimensiones con coordenadas 1,23
entonces la coordenada x es 1 la
coordenada y es 2 y la coordenada zeta
es 3 y luego tengo un plano que pasa por
él y el objetivo del vídeo es hallar una
función l una función l que dependa sólo
de dos variables x de verdad de tal
suerte que la gráfica de esta función l
sea exactamente este plano que estamos
viendo del lado izquierdo
entonces notemos que en realidad hay una
infinidad de planos que pueden pasar por
este punto rojo verdad simplemente por
ejemplo cambiando las direcciones y la
inclinación y los ángulos verdad
entonces nosotros necesitamos una forma
de poder distinguir el que nos interesa
que como veremos digamos más adelante
cuando estamos hablando de gráficas o
más bien de planos tangentes a gráficas
de funciones
se puede calcular con las derivadas
parciales de la función original
entonces veamos una primera observación
qué pasa si queremos evaluar la función
l en el punto 12 bueno como sabemos que
este punto en tres dimensiones está en
la gráfica entonces l de 12 tiene que
ser exactamente igual a 3 verdad porque
será la altura la altura que nos
indicará cómo se gráfica esta función
verdad y eso tiene que ser justamente 3
entonces aquí podemos verlo desde este
punto verdad y ahora pensemos que que
distingue digamos a las gráficas planas
de o de funciones digamos planas de las
que pueden estar un poco curvadas porque
por ejemplo si nosotros interpretamos
con otro plano digamos con el plano de
igual a 2 verdad pensemos que
interceptamos con este plano entonces
podríamos representar esto podría
representar como cambia al movernos en
la dirección de x y fijando el valor de
verdad entonces vemos que estos dos
planos verdad se intersectan
en una línea y esta es la idea
fundamental de los planos de verdad
entonces esta misma idea la podemos
repetir si cambiamos el valor de y
entonces digamos que ahora el valor de g
es igual a 1 verdad y si ahora es igual
a 1 en realidad podemos observar que
esta línea que se genera de inter secar
los planos tienen la misma pendiente
verdad entonces esto en términos de las
derivadas de nuestra función l que
estamos buscando cómo se escribe bueno
esto significa que la derivada parcial
de l con respecto a la variable x verdad
estamos fijando y eso lo movemos a x
esto por supuesto evaluado en el punto x
coma
pues en realidad debe ser una pendiente
constante verdad quiere decir que esto
es un número a que es fijo entonces este
número de aquí es constante y ahora si
nosotros quisiéramos calcular la
derivada parcial de nuestra función l
que estamos buscando pero ahora
derivando con respecto de ye pues
podríamos hacer exactamente la misma
idea verdad por ejemplo podríamos tomar
un valor fijo de x digamos x
a uno y podemos ver nuestro plano del
lado izquierdo entonces vemos que esto
tiene una pendiente constante y en
realidad esto lo podemos hacer
exactamente igual en cualquier otro
valor de equis y obtendremos la misma
pendiente verdad esto nos dice que en la
derivada parcial de nuestra función l
con respecto de por qué estamos fijando
a x verdad y cambiamos esto en cualquier
punto x g será también una constante
digamos vamos a llamarle be a esta
constante pero esto que estamos diciendo
es algo muy muy fuerte verdad porque en
principio estas derivadas parciales pues
pueden ser cualquier función sin embargo
aquí estamos viendo que no son funciones
arbitrarias sino que son funciones
constantes esto es muy muy fuerte verdad
y podemos estimar geométricamente cuáles
serían los valores de a&b verdad por
ejemplo si tomamos ayer constante y nos
fijamos en la línea de la intersección
nos preguntamos cuál es la pendiente y
aquí podemos ver más o menos que esto se
parece a dos verdad nos movemos una
en la dirección horizontal y subimos dos
en la en la dirección vertical verdad
entonces más o menos la pendiente es 2 y
lo mismo podríamos hacer con esta esta
otra constante b verdad que si
interceptamos con este otro plano
podemos ver que esto se parece más o
menos a 1 muy bien entonces ahora lo que
podríamos nosotros hacer es fijarnos
bueno de todas las funciones posibles en
realidad tienen derivadas parciales
constantes qué significa esto bueno esto
significa que nuestra función l que
depende de x y de y al derivar la con
respecto de x nos da simplemente a esto
quiere decir que debe ser algo de la
forma a por x verdad que de hecho en
este caso no está es es 2 verdad es 2
por x más una constante que bueno es una
constante con respecto a la derivación
con respecto a x verdad es decir todo lo
que lo que aparezca en nuestra función l
depende ahora exclusivamente de ye pero
nosotros sabemos que la derivada con
respecto de g
así que esto que sólo dependía debe en
realidad sólo es
porque en este caso es uno por cierto
más cualquier otras cosas que sean
constantes para fines de derivar con
respecto de iu pero además ya eran
independientes de x lo cual nos dice que
esta parte que es constante es constante
para las dos variables verdad así que
vamos a ponerlo como más una constante
sé muy bien entonces podemos ver en este
método que que la función l que estamos
buscando es muy muy restringida verdad
en realidad por ejemplo x sólo aparece
en este término lineal y y el y cuando
hablamos de término lineal quiere decir
que no aparece con potencias ni con
otras composiciones con otras funciones
muy raras como seno o algo por el estilo
verdad entonces lo mismo ocurre para y
ahora bien lo único que nos falta
determinar es el valor de esta constante
c entonces cuánto vale c una idea que
podríamos desarrollar para calcularlo es
evaluar esta función en 12 verdad
evaluamos esta función en 12 y eso
sabemos que nos tiene que dar quedar 3
y entonces simplemente despejamos la
constante ce verdad pero otra idea es
reemplazar esta función o más bien
desplazar la verdad porque por ejemplo
esto lo podríamos reescribir de la
siguiente forma esto es 2 por x menos 1
porque uno es el punto en donde nos
interesa verdad es la coordenada x del
punto que nos interesa más 1 porque
menos la coordenada ya que nos interesa
que es 2 verdad entonces hasta aquí
podemos ver que si distribuimos en
realidad tenemos 2x más 1 por ye verdad
y simplemente estamos restando 2 y
restando 2 acá también entonces estamos
restando 4 si nosotros tenemos aquí una
constante y le restamos 4 pues
esencialmente obtenemos otra constante
que vamos a llamar acá muy bien entonces
tenemos otra constante acá entonces en
realidad hemos hecho esto para que al
evaluar en el punto 12 que es el que nos
interesa todo esto sea mucho más simple
si nosotros evaluamos l en el punto 12
verdad entonces tendremos 2 por x 1 y
sustituimos x igual a 1 verdad y esto
simplemente se cancela verdad si ahora
sustituimos aquí con ya igualados
entonces esto también se cancela y
simplemente nos queda nuestra constante
pero sabemos que esta función evaluada
en 12 tiene que ser igual a 3 entonces
esto de aquí tiene que ser igual a 3 y
por lo tanto esta constante que no
sabíamos quién era en realidad ahora sí
sabemos quién es verdad esa constante
tiene que ser 3 vamos a ponerlo aquí
esta constante tiene que ser 3
entonces fíjate en cómo controlar este
plano verdad tenemos este numerito 2 que
esencialmente es la pendiente con
respecto a la variable x y tenemos este
numerito 1 que esencialmente es la
pendiente pero con respecto a de verdad
y podríamos cambiar estos dos números y
esto es lo que nos da las distintas
pendientes del plano por ejemplo para
este plano particular verdad la
pendiente
con respecto a pues es muy muy pequeña
digamos podríamos pensar que es como 0.1
y la pendiente en la dirección de x pues
es negativa en este caso verdad y pues
simplemente al final ponemos este este
número 3 verdad como constante y este
método es muy poderoso y será importante
que lo recuerdes para el próximo vídeo y
quiero que recuerdes esta idea de cómo
escribir la coordenada digamos como
escribirla en términos de las
coordenadas x 0 verdad 10 0
iceta 0 que es el punto por donde pasa
así como las pendientes con los
coeficientes aquí al frente de verdad
las pendientes con respecto a la
variable xy y bueno con eso terminamos y
nos vemos en el próximo vídeo